welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for the Marvels the sequel to
Captain Marvel but also a sequel to One
Division and to Ms Marvel really a movie
that seems to be finally explaining what
the hell the powers of these Marvel
superheroes are we did it we got there
I'm gonna break down this trailer frame
by lurk and frame for all the details
you might have missed so we can kind of
figure out what's going on in this movie
now I guessed it on some very special
episodes of the break room this week
please go check them out as well as my
analysis of Jaws my favorite movie to
watch with my dad you can see that over
on the Deep dive Channel also please
know that sagafter has informed us that
entertainment Journal is Outlets like
new rock stars are allowed to analyze
movies and TV shows this video here is
not a paid promotion and we support the
actors and the writers who are on strike
right now all right let's get started
prodigal child of the Milky Way
Nick Fury my favorite one-eyed man of
intrigue how goes it out there I am cold
no air space
[Music]
okay the trailer opens with this call
between Captain Marvel Carol Danvers and
with Nick Fury last time we saw Carol
other than that Ms Marvel post credit
scene and that scene seems to take place
during the events of this movie last
time we saw her Carol was joining Wong
Bruce Banner shung Chi and Katie on a
conference call about the 10 rings in
general in the MCU Carol's Focus has
been on interplanetary crises not really
on Earthbound matters meanwhile Nick
Fury is currently finishing out his
story arc on secret evasion and I guess
we can assume he's gonna survive those
events he's back in his eye patch here
after spending most of the season with
no eye patch he did strap one back on at
the end of episode 5 ahead of his final
fight with the scroll gravic this shot
of a ship flying past the ring belt of a
planet is really a mirrored version of a
shot that we saw in the April trailer
Carol is now wearing a new Captain
Marvel suit for this movie and Sean Chi
it was blue above the chest emblem now
it's back to Red on top and blue below
but it seems to switch back and forth
throughout this movie Nick Fury calls
from the saber space station that we saw
a wide shot of in the last trailer and
on the station all the cadets wear these
white and black uniforms which seems to
inspire the suit that Monica Rambo aware
as a superhero that she's gonna evolve
into in this movie Photon Carol answers
her call from her kitchen nook on her
ship and includes a stove some cookware
containing of gummy bears behind her
some A1 steak sauce so she must hate
herself also some extraterrestrial
plants that remind me of the plants that
the eternals kept on their ship the Domo
meanwhile in Fury's sweet there's a
couch corner with open laptops and what
looks like a telescope maybe so we can
look down at the Indian Ocean to see if
Tiamat might ever blink or maybe so that
he could make sure his wife Priscilla
ain't making tea for Mr Postman Carol's
bookshelf is a photo of Maria Rambo
Monica's mother as well as a photo of
the American southwest in an article
about astronaut Monica Rambo from the
Magnolia weekly local Louisiana and
shoots for the stars I tried to make up
the article here's what I could read a
local Louisiana woman has set her sights
on the Stars after graduating from Rice
University with a degree in Psychology
and physics and astronomy monogrambo
something something the next paragraph
Rambo said that when she was 11 years
old and suddenly suddenly something
upload your trailers in 4k Disney for
the love of God now it's worth noting
that when Monica was around that age she
actually played Uno cards with Gaia
talos's daughter Emily Clark's character
in secret Invasion also on Carol's shelf
is a green book titled lunar mystery and
the only MCU lunar mystery I care about
is whether Joaquin torres's conspiracy
theory is true that Steve Rogers is
still alive living on the moon this is a
movie that can finally address it Goose
the flirt and flips on a burner that
boils water to brew some coffee good
good not cat Carol reports that she
feels cold and airless in space
remindedness of the adventure that she's
saved in a past movie Tony Stark who
nearly froze and suffocated to death on
a ship with nebula next there's a pretty
crazy shot of Carol and Goose both
floating in open space just a reminder
that as a cosmic irradiated individual
she can survive in space but in the past
when she does this she's been like
glowing radiation as she does and I
guess Goose as an alien flirkin just
doesn't need oxygen or air pressure
either but really this is just something
the MC fudges all the time the moment
you enter open space without any
pressure your body should just like
crumple but whatever it's a comic movie
let's move on
[Music]
annihilator
later he took everything from me
and now I'm returning the favor
you probably noticed the Marvel Studios
title card has the S transition into the
sash of The Miz Marvel kamalakon
Insignia Caro flies toward this floating
formation of a diamond-shaped ship
surrounded by four smaller versions of
it which seems to be the battle
formation of the cree General Dar Ben
the villainous movie played by Zoe
Ashton darbin in the comics is a Creed
General who along with ale Don became
joint Emperors of the cree Empire for a
time and they created an Android version
of the Silver Surfer in this movie
darbin is a member of the accusers part
of the same order of Cree militant
extremists as Ronan the Accuser from
Guardians of the Galaxy in the first
Captain Marvel film which is why in this
movie darben carries a similar cosme Rod
but she calls Carol the annihilator
which is really interesting because the
annihilators were a group of Heroes from
the Abnet Landing run of the Marvel
Comics in 2011 following the
annihilation wave storyline and the
cancer verse Invasion Cosmo the space
dog aims to fulfill the dream of the
Fallen Star-Lord with a new Galactic
dream team that includes Quasar Silver
Surfer Ronan the Accuser Beta Ray Bill
Gladiator and icon AKA space Knight
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 introduced
phyla and in the comics phyla Vel
becomes a a version of Quasar I don't
know there might just be a few Clues
here that this movie could finally
introduce the Silver Surfer to the MCU
and since the Silver Surfer is normally
known as The Herald of Galactus we know
what that would be
darbin uncovers the other bangle the one
that goes on the other wrist it seems to
be covered in space dust on the outside
but on the inside clean as a whistle
this bangle is on darbin's left arm
whereas kamala's Bengals on her right
this Bengal found its way to Kamala
after her great grandmother an outcast
from the nor Dimension found this Bengal
on a severed blue arm Cree or sometimes
blue skinned and they found this in
ruins in the Indian subcontinent marked
with a symbol of the ten rings so one
wonders if the Bengals and the tin Rings
were both ancient Cree technology that
found their way to earth when darben
hammers her bangle with the cosme rod a
purple pillar of energy beams up from it
which could be a rift through space-time
or through Dimensions like the one
kamala's bangle was capable of opening
hey remember when all those villains
against Marvel turn into Ash skeletons
like they were in an Indiana Jones movie
yeah that happened in the MCU all right
let's move on
laughs
what is happening to me yeah I love how
this trailer and it's the music of the
Beastie Boys Intergalactic so that as
darbin pops on that bangle we hear the
distorted another dimension the song is
re-edited though so that we hear one
punctuated version of these another
dimension every time we cut to a new
Marvel in this section the three are
cosmically entangled in this film Carol
swaps into kamala's room Kamala swaps
into Monica's spacesuit and presumably
Monica will swap to wherever Carol was
and already we should be pretty
concerned because as Monica floats
toward a glitched hexagonal portal of
the UNT and grid that we've seen in past
MCU movies she reaches out to touch it
and her bare hand is an open freaking
space outside of her spacesuit so really
it's the cmbr cosmic microwave
background radiation that we learned
about in Wanda Vision it's the
electromagnetic field that comes all the
way back from The Big Bang that makes up
the grid and links these women together
so that Carol's gloveless hand connects
through space-time with Monica's hand to
make it seem temporarily exposed to
space and notice for all three it is the
right hand the arm that Kamala has the
bangle on that does this it's an
entanglement cursed on them by darbin
and using the other bangle moving on now
people who only know me from watching my
videos are sometimes surprised to learn
that I am more than just a nerdy torso
it's true
I know it's weird
to see them up it but if I'm leaving the
blue dungeon to go to the park or a
friend's house or a pool those lights
need pants specifically a bird dogs bird
dogs look and feel so good they're
stretch khaki shorts fit Slimmer through
the thigh and the leg to make you look
sculpted thank you so much bird dogs see
most shorts are made with stiff
restricting cotton but not bird dogs
they use the cloud knit fabric that
looks like khaki but moves better fits
Slimmer and Wicks away sweat so you can
stay cool dry and good looking all day
long and if you go to birddogs.com new
rockstars or use the code new rockstars
at checkout you'll get a free Yeti style
tumbler with your order
awesome once again that's birddogs.com
new rockstars or use the code new rock
stars to check out to get a free tumbler
with your order you won't want to take
your bird dogs off we promise you
she's entangled our light based powers
so we switch places whenever we use them
strong Theory you can absorb light
I can see it and Kamala who's Kamala hi
she can turn light into physical matter
which I have never heard of okay we see
New York from the Jersey City side of
the river that's Kamala Khan's
neighborhood and inside the con living
room Carol sees her hand moment after a
swap with either Monica or with Kamala
as director Anita Costa does a reverse
Dolly Zoom to show Carol readjusting to
her space in the room Monica lands on
the furniture and notice there are
crazed soldiers probably part of
darbin's accuser order attacking but if
you look closely at the shot of Monica
it is gooses tendrils on the right side
of frame that these Cree are actually
scrambling away from both this trailer
and the last trailer seemed to re-edit
what the actual swaps will be in the
movie Just in the trailers to give us a
clearer sense of this Cosmic handcuffed
conceit so here Monica punches and it
syncs with Kamala Landing beside a wall
of hard light on the saber space station
but those might be from different parts
of the movie we see a shot of Carol
flying above that planet where she
approached darbin's Diamond ships before
with a purple hexagonal Grid in the sky
behind her so in general in this movie
it seems like the untn transportation
grid is broken it's shut down down
because the cosmic radiation that
enables that grid also enables these
three Marvels it's the same kind of
radiation source and they've been
glitched by darbin so that no one in the
MCU right now can Lightspeed jump into
Earth's coordinates to help us it's put
the entire universe known in the MCU in
a very dangerous spot Monica explains
that Carol can absorb light Monica can
see it and Kamala can turn light into
physical matter of the three I gotta say
based off this description Monica's
ability to just see the light is kind of
the Short Straw we did see her ability
to see the radiation from her point of
view in one division after she passed
through that hex wall but I think she's
selling herself short because remember
her body was also capable of phasing
bullets through her torso so maybe that
can be explained by her disability to
see the bullets as radiation and her own
body is radiation kind of like Neo able
to see the lines of code making up
everything in the Matrix and using that
knowledge to stop bullets also in the
living room you can see that Kamala is
holding the tablet that seems to show
her bangle as they are trying to figure
out what the spangle is and how it works
exactly all right on to the next clip I
could totally show you no
so Kamala eager to prove herself to
these Heroes fires up her bangle and
immediately swaps with Carol as Carol
was flying so that Carol now crash lands
in the living room and Kamala appears in
the sky falling to her death on her
shirt are two issues of Captain Marvel
Comics it seems to show Captain Marvel
number 18 but the layout of the cover
doesn't really match any release Captain
Marvel Comics at least in our reality
but there is an issue of number 18 in
the Captain Marvel Comics in 2019 where
she wields the cosme rod it seems like
they just designed new ones so at this
point the breakdown I'm not going to
continue showing trailer clips with the
audio because they have too much Beastie
Boys music in it and we don't want to
get flagged for that but I'm just going
to analyze what we see in here in the
shots of New York in this trailer we do
not see Avengers Tower anywhere trust me
we looked ever since far from home I
have been scanning every New York
skyline in every MCU title that's set in
here in New York and I'm telling you
right now these MCU titles are just
avoiding establishing any new continuity
with the current status of Avengers
Tower normally in the MCU it's in the
position of the real-life MetLife
building in Midtown Manhattan right by
Grand Central Station in recent months
I've speculated they could be tangberry
and Mr Griffin who took it over based
off the fact that there was a prune Kang
qeng Tower in the void but we've also
been hearing some rumors that Avengers
Tower could be a Mephisto deal don't
tempt me not to tame a Fisto okay we see
the untn crisis over this new planet
that we talked about in the last trailer
breakdown that I think is aladna that's
the planet from Captain Marvel number
nine in 2014 based on Prince yon being
in this movie that's a planet where
people speak in Rhymes and historically
women choose men to be their mates kind
of in a Sadie Hawkins situation here we
see water from aladna's Ocean sucking up
into the broken hexagonal grid Carol
confronts darbin with a cosme ride and
it looks like one of darbin's teeth is
metallic interesting then a shot of Dar
Ben looking intense with a cosme rod
stepping up on the Cliffside as we hear
Carol saying she's targeting every
planet we call home so I guess that
would mean Earth Earth and Earth yeah
probably also holla and aladna it just
seems like Carol has homes everywhere
but this Cliffside if it's not a
different planet kind of looks like the
Cliffs of new Asgard in Norway so will
we see a second Ragnarok in this movie
like if you're darb and trying to take
out Galactic enemies to the cree Empire
the people have Asgard might be on her
Hit List a Lander tumbles through the
air over the city and inside you can see
plurk and tendrils pressed against the
glass and this Lander flies past the
Statue of Liberty which is bronze
colored and I love the love bit of
continuity here because in Spider-Man no
way home the statue was deoxidized from
green to bronze and Captain America's
shield was added remember during that no
way home battle The Shield fell off the
statue yet the statue kept its bronze
color and actually in Ms Marvel and
Disney plus originally when it premiered
in June 2022 establishing shots of the
Statue of Liberty showed it back to its
normal green but sometimes since then
when you check it now on Disney plus
they swapped in new bfx to make it
bronze they fixed it so that it better
matches this movie I assume I'm just
fascinated whenever they do this but if
you look closely at the upper left
corner of that copper statue it looks
like she is back holding the shield
above her head you can see the corner of
the shield in the corner and I don't
know if it's just me but it kind of
looks like lady Liberty's eyes are now
looking slightly more Upward at it then
on the safer station behind Nick Fury
one of the cadets is this yellow skinned
race which we've seen in the MCU in the
Guardians of the Galaxy movies these are
called aacons some of whom are among the
ravagers and in the comics are long time
enemies of the cree Empire also known as
the belt buckle of one of these Cadets
you can see saber's logo which looks
pretty much just like a dollar sign it's
an S with a thin sword running through
it we can probably afford to redesign
saber PR team there's an interesting
shot of Kamala in her normal clothes as
this earthy background is Shifting
around her kind of looks like a place is
being destroyed or terraformed and
noticed this green-skinned alien fleas
maybe a scroll Brandon actually pitched
that since Kamala can open Rifts in
space and time she might be revisiting
the destruction of the scroll Homeworld
of skrillos by the cree Empire something
that the secret Invasion opening titles
has been depicting with a uh the people
of aladna engaged in a ceremonial dance
as Prince Young dances with and dips
Carol Danvers it seems like Prince Young
may be the current or former spouse that
Carol took some time in her past off
world Monica tells Carol you are not the
only thing standing between this and the
universe and beside this window that
looks out on a rainy cityscape I think
this is the cree Homeworld of Hala that
we saw in the 2019 Captain Marvel film
but the question I have is what is this
is it just Dar Ben's threat or something
greater and in the universe does that
mean just the other two marvels or are
there other Cosmic teammates from places
other than Earth that Monica's hintinan
like Silver Surfer Nova blue Marvel ways
our legendary Star-Lord other members of
the Guardians of the Galaxy mantis the
Marvels fight a group of Cree accusers
in their traditional headgear kind of
looks like an attempted assault on a lot
now then a group of flirt and kittens
float around the saber space station
does the space station lose artificial
gravity at some point is it gonna crash
in space Carol flies away from the ship
which looks like the large
diamond-shaped darbin mother ship that
we saw earlier in the trailer then three
great hero shots of each hero Carol
after smashing through some Creed
warships on the aladna coast Monica
glowing in a powerful light her eyes now
glowing white saying higher setting up
the other two to complete Carroll
Danvers hire further faster catchphrase
that she and Monica's Mother Maria
shared I think this is a moment Monica
will complete her transformation into
the hero Photon and it's the power that
she will share with her mother not just
by using her call sign of photon but
really a cosmic connection as Maria was
Captain Marvel in Another Universe
Kamala pulls off a great move of casting
hard light to create a smooth
frictionless slide for herself to kick a
crease Soldier she also uses this in the
next shot where the three of them team
up against darbin Kamala creates
platforms from Monica to Lily Pad across
Carol has the cosme rod here but
remember Dar Ben has the other Bengal
and that seems to be the Ultimate Weapon
okay on to the final clip
who's that good getting close
down
oh my God oh my God
I can't can you I got it yeah I love how
they use the Beastie Boys shout on the
fork and grab Intergalactic really is
the best song choice of this because
it's a team of three having to come
together to synchronize on a rhyme at
the end of each verse and in this final
shot it seems like Carol has changed her
Captain Marvel's suit yet again now it
is blue on top let me know what your
favorite part of this trailer is what
you're most looking forward to from the
movie subscribe to all three channels in
the new rockstars Network and we'll see
you next time bye